trong sáng ngày tại phủ chú tịch, tổng bị thư tô lâm và phù nhân đã chủ gí lấy đóng trọng thế
bị thư thứ nhất chủ tính nước của vào Mì Gàn Diya Càn Nen và phù nhân.
Tổng bị thư tô lâm và phù nhân trọng, đồng chiến Mì Gàn Diya Càn Nen và phù nhân sẵn tham câm nhả nước Việt Nam.
Lúng vào dịch Việt Nam trọng thế tổ chức lễ kiện nghiệm tảm mi năm cách mạng tháng tảm,
cũng khảy mũ hài thẳng chiến, thẳng định truyến thăm tạo dấu mốt quan trọng
và lúc lực mạng mẽ để tất tục cùng cổ mở giống,
nâng tập và làm sâu sắc hơn quan hệ loàn kết truyền thống,
hiểu nghị đặc biệt và hợp tắt toàn dễ Việt Nam của bà.
Tổng bị thư tổ lâm và bí thư thứ nhất chủ tịch,
mi Gàn Diya Càn Nen đã thông báo cho nhau về tình hình mối lúc,
cùng chào đổi thống nhất các phương hướng, biệt pháp,
nhằm tiếp tục đưa mối quan hệ hiểu nghị truyền thống đặc biệt Việt Nam của bà,
cũng như một số bánh đe của bật và khu tế cùng phần tâm.
Bí thư thứ nhất chủ tình nước của bà,
mi Gàn Diya Càn Nen,
chân thành cảm ơn sự lỏn tiếp sọng thiệt,
chân tình và chủ đáo.
Hẳng định những thành tiểu của nhân dân Việt Nam trong tạm mi năm xe dân và bảo vệ tổ quốc,
chính là ngôn cổ vũ, động viên to lớn, lù viên nhân dân của bà.
Nhanh dị này, tổng bị thư tổ lâm chuyển lời tham hỏi,
đến đại tướng rao ngon kest trô,
lãnh tụ kích mạng của bà và khăn lồng chi lãnh đạo cao cấp của bà.
Và cũng trong sang này,
hồi kênh bí thư thứ nhất chủ tình nước của bà,
mi Gàn Diya Càn Nen,
chủ tình nước lần cường bui mừng chào đón người bà thành phía bà khi mến tổng dân Việt Nam,
chờ lại không sau bệnh nắm và là lần đầu tiên trên tương vị lãnh đạo đứng đầu gạm,
và nhắn nước của bà.
Đánh ra cao sự hiện dễn của đoàn tại sự kiện kiện nghiệp trọng đại của dân tổ Việt Nam.
Cái nhận tình cảm, lồng chi anh em,
và sự uống hộ quý bà hút của đàn nhắn nước nhân dân của bà,
dành cho sự hiệp cách bà của Việt Nam.
Tình tưởng Việt Nam với nên tàn và cơ đồ sau gần buồn với lòng đột mới,
sẽ tiếp tục dành được nhiều kết quả tích thường thân nữa trong công cuộc bà về xây dựa và phát triển đất.
Cảm ơn món quả đây,
ý nghĩa của nhân dân Việt Nam không qua trên trình uống hộ tòan quốc với chỗ đây,
sau mi lòng năm, nghĩa tình Việt Nam của bà.
Và có đỏ là biểu hiện sinh đậu của trên thống đàn kết và hợp tác anh em giữa đàn,
nhắn nước và nhân dân hành nước.
Hãy nhá lãnh đạo cũng khẳng lịch tất tâm làm sâu sát hơn nữa,
mới khoản hệ mẫu mực Việt Nam của bà.
Đất chủ tịch hồ chí mình và chủ tịch P đàn các sâu,
lạc nên mỏng và nhiều thệ lãnh đạo và nhân dân hành nước để tổn vôn đọc.